أريد أن أبدأ بما قلته في وقت سابق من
هذا الأسبوع قلت إننا في الأردن
لا يمكننا الاعتماد فقط على الولايات المتحدة لفعل
كل شيء من أجلنا ، نحن اليوم حليف
أقل قوة
وأقل موثوقية للأردن ،
ولا تزال الولايات المتحدة قوية جدًا.
شريك الأردن صديق حقيقي
للأردن ، لقد ساعدنا التعاون الذي حصلنا عليه
معنا بشكل كبير في
التخفيف من العديد من التحديات التي
كنا في الطرف المتلقي
نتيجة للأزمات الإقليمية ، لذا فإن
الشراكة قوية إنها قوية  إن
الدعم الأمريكي للأردن هو مفتاح ليس فقط
لتمكيننا من مواجهة تلك التحديات ولكن
أيضًا في مساعدتنا على تنفيذ
الإصلاحات الاقتصادية واسعة النطاق التي نقوم
بها الآن. ما
قصدته بهذا البيان هو أننا
في المنطقة أه بحاجة  للقيام بالكثير من
الرفع الثقيل ، لا يمكننا الاعتماد
علينا فقط لحل مشاكلنا ، وعلينا أن نقوم
بدورنا في ذلك ، ثم نعمل
معنا كشريك موثوق به ، ثم المضي
قدمًا
، هل أنت قلق بشكل خاص مثل الولايات المتحدة.
بعيدًا عن الشرق الأوسط
وأكثر تجاه علاقته بالصين
، هل أنت قلق بشأن من يملأ
الفراغ ، لقد كانت روسيا بالتأكيد أكثر
نشاطًا في الشرق الأوسط مما كانت عليه في السنوات
الماضية.
بحاجة إلى هذا
الدور
ونعمل أه معنا على
ضمان استمراره أه لمساعدتنا أه في
مواجهة كل تلك التحديات
وإيجاد حلول لها
والمناقشات التي كان من دواعي سروري
أن أجريها مع وزير الخارجية
أمس أشارت إلى
أننا سنواصل العمل معًا مرة أخرى
من نقطة الانطلاق حيث نقوم بواجبنا
في المنطقة وكذلك سواء فيما
يتعلق بعملية السلام ، إرهاب اللاجئين السوريين
، نحن شريك رئيسي
لنا وسنواصل العمل معًا
سوريا  الآن
قصة نجاة ملحوظة يمكن للمرء أن يقولها
فيما يتعلق ببشار الأسد
وقيادته لسوريا
أعاد الأردن فتح حدوده مع
سوريا ، وهناك رحلات جوية
بين دمشق ودمشق مرة أخرى.  الملك عبد الله تحدث
مع الزعيم السوري هل الأردن
يستعد لتطبيع العلاقات مع
سوريا
ما نقوم
به في الأردن يحاول أه
التأكد من أن هناك عملية سياسية جادة
ستؤدي إلى إنهاء تلك
الأزمة والأردن كما تعلمون جيداً
لقد كنا في الطرف المتلقي
لتلك الأزمة 1.3 مليون لاجئ سوري
في الأردن خطر الإرهاب
من الحدود الآن تهديدات المخدرات
القادمة عبر الحدود
ما نراه هو أنه بعد
11 عامًا من الأزمة لدينا  لنفعل
ما يلزم لحلها لا يمكننا
الاستمرار في المضاعفة على
المناهج التي لم تحقق
النتيجة وبالتالي ما نحاول
القيام به هو بالتنسيق مع الولايات
المتحدة والشركاء الآخرين أه إيجاد طريق
نحو أأ سياسي أه  الحل
هناك بعدين لعلاقة
سوريا أحدهما ثنائي والثنائي مرة أخرى أه
كدولة مجاورة بحدود 367
كلم أثر تلك
الأزمة علينا كان هائلاً أه لا
تعلو  منها عبء أه
توفير حياة كريمة للاجئين
الذي أه للأسف
الذين نراه أقل فأقل
اهتمامًا عالميًا تجاههم والجانب الآخر
منه هو أننا بحاجة للعمل نحو
حل سياسي نتفق جميعًا أنه
لا يوجد رد عسكري
و  تسببت الأزمة في الكثير من المعاناة
والدمار ولا يمكننا الاستمرار
في سياسة الوضع الراهن وهذا
ما يحاول الأردن القيام به لفتح
أفق لحل سياسي.